c'est ça oui parce que je trouve que
vous verrouillez beaucoup mais parfois
vous n'êtes pas sur le coup il ya un
truc qui me choque beaucoup c'est des
bandes annonces de films violents ça que
moi j'aime bien parfois comme tout père
de famille j'aime bien parfois pouvoir
laisser mon gosse devant la télé quand
ça m'arrange quelques minutes et à des
heures où c'est pas trop dangereux et
parfois il ya des bandes annonces et
remet à partir du moment où je vais vous
le dire ou le film a eu tel signalétique
et que bon ben on n'a pas à ce moment là
à dire quoi que ce soit sur la bande
mais vous avez raison les bandes sont
souvent comme toute sa vie comme
d'autres comme tout pub un raccourci
violent mais moi je vais vous dire une
chose je n'aime pas ça comme je n'aime
pas non plus ce qui fonde qui sont qui
sont pour la drogue
moi je suis tout à fait contre état pour
la légalisation je suis content et je
vais vous dire une chose terrible
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et d'amitié pour
vous le savez j'aime pas quand dans vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabba nie cependant le caractérise et
ses canons mais non moi je moi je vous
dis raison président moi je suis content
je suis content je suis content que je
dis que chacun fait ce qu'il veut dans
son coin mais dans une émission et
notamment une émission de service public
on peut pas faire la promo de sart brad
qu'elle attendait dans tout le monde
peut aller ou non mais si j'ai un
reproche à vous faire c'est celui
largement d'ailleurs je vous le dis
comme ça entre nous
[Musique]